since the industrial revolution
we didn't have a point
of so much leverage
but now even more than in the past
a single individual a single contributor
a single software engineer
can have an amazing leverage
bring its impact so think about the
impact that one live line of code
one
file can have
globally that's amazing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with lumitec sponsored by homeward
ventures hippo insurance oppos labs
synergy global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel serena partners and in
media partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet gal
aviv the cto of digital turbine's ab
growth platform and the general manager
of the company's israel site
in his role aviv leads the global r d
team developing digital turbines mobile
monetization and user acquisition
solutions a key part of the company's
independent mobile growth platform
gall joined startup company interactive
in 2013 and has led the building and
scaling of the company's technology
through two exits and acquisitions
interactive became fiber in 2018 and he
kicked off his career in the israeli air
force as a software engineer and
engineering manager serving as a captain
in the r d unit
gal is the founder of the non-profit
devops training program cloud school an
early stage investor and serves on
several advisory boards including offic
324 alumni association the apple seeds
academy joined and spot io which was
recently acquired by netapp he studied
software engineering and holds an
executive mba from the hebrew university
in jerusalem
gal your
career that you've had is fascinating
touching both on on deep research within
highly bureaucratic systems like the
israeli air force but also highly
innovative transitioning also working
with investments and being working a
little bit with with jvp and being on
the advisory boards of some of the most
phenomenal startups in the in the
ecosystem like spot io and later on vice
president r d of interactive which was
sold to fiber being cto of fiber and
then which was sold to digital turbine
and today
obviously general general manager and a
cto position within digital turbine so
gal
how do you describe sort of your thought
process through the career that you've
had
okay so
first of all thank you for this amazing
intro i think i couldn't do it better
myself
and before we begin you know i want to
say it like um being a cto of such a
huge company and managing such a large
operation but i want to make it super
clear i'm i'm a software engineer in my
mind and soul and and my entire heart
and that's always my favorite part of
what we are doing
and
you know i think that the the
interesting part to look at when we are
watching this journey for the last
decade
is actually
the way you are doing from
building
the actual technology of a very small
startup setting the foundations
of what's going to be like a world-scale
platform
from their very early days of having
almost
like nothing very small team writing
most of the code like you know handling
production during weekends
and
and then you know scanning it more and
more uh both looking at the team but
also with their technology
and our story begins like actually the
story begins more than a decade ago
i think i began my way and i began my
weight coding in a very early age like i
think maybe six years old or something
i'm not sure um you know you asked for
him
for a funny story some funny facts about
me and one of the things i got to
remember was wow i was in zombit which
was kind of an israeli tech show many
many years ago when i was very young and
i think i'm actually i'm writing code
since i can remember myself
but my my journey began at the
the software research and development
unit of the israeli air force
today it's named the office 324 but it
had like different name in the past it
wasn't that popular as it is today you
know when i when i joined um
the israeli air force and the rnd unit
the type of people who were joining
those units
uh were kind of different than what we
see today
and
i i studied my my first my bachelor
degree before it was like uh part of the
academic reserve where you call it
which is the plan where you study for
your first degree before the military
service
and actually what i was building with
during those years today i'm serving i'm
still serving like i'm not serving now
but but um
in reserve the captain of the unit
but actually what we were building in
the unit without getting into too many
details
is extremely
mission-critical or life-critical
high-scale real-time systems
and i think that the most interesting
part is the way you understand the
opportunity you have
to use stuff you were building when it
comes to like those
hard criterias of being like mission
critical and then translating it to
what's relevant outside of those you
know mission critical systems uh i was
serving for about um
seven years in total in the unit
and after i left i i joined a amazing
author who founded the small startup
company in a field which at the time was
almost unknown it's called ethic like a
combination of advertising and
technology and you know it was still
like on the edge of like between second
generation and third generation of
mobile phones it was very early days and
even the concept of like trading in like
like ad space
over what mobile
devices like you had second generation
mobile devices didn't mean a lot when it
comes to headspace
and these were very early days and i
actually joined uh to build technology
but make sure that that it's scalable
and the interesting thing is about and
again i'm i must say i was never
interested in advertising when people
talk to me about marketing and
advertising and i'm like coming from you
know building those
mission critical systems like
that's that's not interesting what
like i was busy building stuff that is
supposed to help saving people's life
you know for example i was part of the
team building the systems that knew how
to alert on time when a missile is about
to to
impact like a
specific neighborhood wow
but the interesting thing is
yeah but but the thing is that you could
see that the potential when it comes to
attack
is the
scale in real time
these were also the kind of early days
of
aws and later on gtp becoming more
popular
when it comes to
automatically scaling systems okay it
was something that was not that familiar
at the time again i'm talking about more
than a decade ago and these were the
early days of start building like
automatically scalable systems
and
we just combined you know the expertise
of like building mission critical
systems you know talking in the terms of
nines like
uh
talking about three nines or four nines
like meaning 99.9 percent availability
of a system it was something super
relevant when you talk about um
platforms that you are building is part
of and like the military service or
mission critical air platforms but then
translating it into advertising
technology making sure that you are able
to serve like very a huge amount of
traffic
in with very high availability of your
systems
that was not trivial uh especially back
in those days
and
one of the things uh we figured is that
if we will be early enough
at this like smart enough in this early
enough stage of building the
infrastructure
it might be super beneficial in the
future
so we built the foundations of the
technology it took us some years to have
our first like a financial event or like
you you know people like to call it in
israel and exit uh but we will actually
acquire we were acquired for the first
time by a public company and then we
went from being interactive a private
privately held small israeli startup by
the way i can call it a garage startup
and it was actually
like a garage startup it was like space
between garages here in the industrial
arena of peta
which is kind of incredible
industrial area of tel aviv i would say
so kind of you know extreme
way of
naming it
yeah it was it was cool and the first
acquisition was
for i would say it was about 86 million
dollars
and again it was some years ago so at
the time 86 million dollars was supposed
to be matched today you know it's like
round day around before many startups
but these were the different days
and you were acquired by a public
company it was named fiber it was traded
in europe
and shortly after the acquisition
something kind of amazing happened and
us as the leadership of the small
startup which was the fourth or fifth
one acquired by the huge fiber at the
time
we were nominated to lead the new
company to to lead their fiber and i was
nominated as cto of the acquiring
company
how does that happen by the way because
it wasn't
right how does that happen that you're
joining a new company you know company
acquires you and all of a sudden you
find yourself yourself in a position of
a leadership of the parent company which
is publicly traded in europe how does
that transition happen
so you know i must say it was it was
these were crazy days and for for many
reasons one of them is that the company
acquired four or five companies one
after the other at the time like fiber
acquired few companies
uh interactive i believe was the most
recent and the biggest one when it comes
to the cost of the acquisition
if i'm not mistaken again it was some
years ago but the point was that we had
like interactive head like really
amazing financial and
business and technological performance
by the way also big part of the other is
sub-products or companies which were
acquired but we had the potential to
lead this to the next step
and few things happened it would be like
too long to get into the details but few
things which are related to three major
aspects like products technology and
business came together and created the
opportunity for us to take the
leadership for the entire company
now the interesting thing was that
now okay you have the result which is
the acquisition of many uh
the result of many acquisitions and now
you need to integrate
not only
not only products like you need to make
sure that you're building one integrated
product suite but also that you are
integrating technologies
and the most complicated people you know
different cultures
you need to build trust
and you know i must say that i think
that the biggest challenge at the time
was the cultural gaps
uh not the technological gaps by the way
you know always say technology
technology is easy once you build trust
and understanding between between teams
technology is easy
um
but
the different the gaps in culturing
technology like in technical culture in
personal culture between the states
and europe and tel aviv that was big and
that was like
lots of work to to like to build and to
make it like one solid ecosystem
and i think that about for about two
years starting the day i stepped into
the position
i was splitting my time
mostly between israel and europe but
also the states and that was crazy it
was like actually you know um
like this movie up in the air
um when you like just travel
um
from from one from one destination to
another i was spending like half of my
time in israel and therefore my time
just in other states and it was it was
crazy
um
unbelievable
that's unbelievable yeah so but but it
did enable us to to integrate eventually
and consolidate all of the different
sub-products into one strong company
which was just recently i would say
about a year ago
going for another financial event again
another exit this time we're acquired by
a nasdaq traded company
a pretty famous one digital turbine
its symbol is apps
nasdaq
and
again it was the biggest and the most
recent
after a few acquisitions by digital
turbine which included also
ed colony and the israeli startup
appreciate as well
shortly after
i was asked to take the leadership for
the entire israel operation which
includes also
the appreciate technology and some
former digital turbine technology based
here as well
um and in parliament to this also to
take the position of the cto of the
entire app growth side of digital
turbine which is the edtech-related
aspect of its entire technology
so that's actually what we are doing now
and that's what i'm building now
um
and
i i need a i need a breath
from hearing about this crazy journey on
all the different transitions you've
made here you know from
a from interactive you know privately
held israeli company to transitioning to
now being multinational and being in a
leadership leadership position in a
publicly traded company where you're now
and you as the cto and as an engineer
from
priestly when you were born you're
basically saying that you know techno
once you figure out culture and people
technology you know technology gets
there and that's a big thing for
somebody from somebody in your position
and then going through another shift and
now being in a leadership position
within a u.s
nasdaq company a us publicly traded
company and and and dealing all in a
world of extreme scale but in a world
that you never actually intended of
necessarily getting into marketing in
that tech
yeah so you know i think that first of
all it was an amazing journey and i must
say
that i think that there are
very few constellations
that can make somebody who is mostly
about tech and engineering
stay and and grow together with a
company or companies but you know when
you when you build a team and when you
build technology and you build stuff for
so long and you are so strongly invested
um
you really feel you have an opportunity
to build something which is bigger than
the sum of its parts
i think that the most interesting point
to
understand you
and looking a little bit about about the
business so yes i'm not i'm not about
marketing i'm not a marketing guy and
they're not about
advertising that's not my thing it's
about technology
um
but
i'm also
um
into engineering and i'm also into scale
and we need to understand something when
we are talking about a company like
digital turbine
investing
so much in acquisitions most of them in
israel but also globally just to to get
a bit of understanding only in the past
year digital turbine invested um
about more than one billion dollar in
tech
acquisitions
now looking at the core assets of
digital turbine
which is the presence yeah and and by
the way today digital turbine has
presence like code bases on device code
presence
on more than 700 million devices
globally
when you take this and you connect it to
the scale
of wow
the ethics side of the company
which is let's say hundreds of millions
of live transactions every minute
you get like amazing opportunities okay
now of course there are aspects of data
privacy and so on but
this is engineering in scale right so
when we are talking about technological
opportunities bringing scale
that's exactly where you made it and
that's exactly when
also israel like israeli engineers has
the opportunity to be part of something
like really global and much much bigger
incredible
incredible i have a question for you
guys
if you're looking at this engineering
feat of global and scale and obviously
you're in
the space and you're both you know
heavily investing in but you're also the
technologies that you're building with
digital turbine and having code run
obviously on i can't believe how many
devices you were mentioning before
what do you what did you learn as a
leader as an engineering leader and as a
company leader when you're leading teams
in the world of scale what is sort of
the leadership
um experience that you have to exude on
other people and with other people
to get to a point where you're doing
skill properly because everybody loves
the word skill but how do you actually
lead it lead an organization to do scale
in a way that maintains
the quality
and allows the organization to grow
innovatively
while maintaining its high scale
okay i love this question i can i really
love it because it touches
the core essence of what i love talking
about when it comes to engineering first
of all
the way i look at it there is a huge
difference
especially when i hire people but there
is a huge difference
between programmers and people who write
code
to software engineers
and i'm a strong believer in software
engineering okay and and it's different
coding is not software engineering
and how is it connected to scale
so thinking about the numbers okay let's
talk about the fact that potentially we
are touching hundreds or millions of
millions or even billions of devices and
users globally okay once i try to
analyze it it seems like 1.3 billion
different users are going for our
servers every month
just you know some kind of idea now
since the industrial revolution
we didn't have a point
of so much leverage
but now even more than in the past
a single individual a single contributor
a single software engineer
can have an amazing leverage
bring its impact so think about the
impact that one live line of code
one
file can have
globally that's amazing you know we
didn't have this like that that was
the entire thing behind the industrial
revolution in the past amazing but today
it's much more
like you you we we have no such
situation in history with this huge
leverage but
with an opponent i always say with
opportunity
come the responsibility
and the way i see it there is no real
difference between a software engineer
and the structural engineer
and you know when you walk around the
city
when you drive over bridges
and you look around you know you see all
those sky campers scarpers and you see
all those buildings and you go through
elevators
you know you you want to know
that a solid engineer has planned and
signed
all this stuff around you right because
if it was not done by solid engineers
who understand the fundamentals
behind the basics of what they are doing
you couldn't
feel safe right and we had like cities
falling apart around us
and that's exactly
how i see engineering for scale and
again that's our responsible
responsibility building the next
generation of platforms of global
scale systems
and making sure that it will not
not only be good for
a you know bringing is bringing some
investors and money on board but
actually serve us globally in scale and
i think that that's the most interesting
i think that
i think that what you're saying here is
is phenomenal and i i just love and and
i'm inspired by your outlook as an
engineer as an engineering leader as a
coder
and but and as someone who who's who i
can see is so passionate about the way
that the way that these organizations
are being led and the way that you're
thinking through so intentionally your
own leadership style and so
complementing that of the organization
and at the end understanding the global
complexities of what you're dealing with
but at the end it all comes to people
and it all comes to culture and it all
comes to us working together
it doesn't matter if you're a software
engineer it doesn't matter if you're the
ceo or president and and that is a huge
takeaway of mine from from these 20
short but very meaningful minutes and i
really want to thank you for your time
and for your effort and for your energy
i know how busy you are and i can't wait
to to share this with friends and family
and and other entrepreneurs around the
world so thank you very very much girl
thank here thank you michael
have a great day
[Music]